hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm
checking out a trailer for a film that
just to trade for a film that just
dropped daddy's home
it's Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg I
love the other guys I completely forgot
they were working together again so I'm
excited to suck up jazz that car can't
beep today I'm excited to check out this
trailer because I love the two of them
together Mark Wahlberg rating comedies
Will Ferrell hit and miss but whatever
I've always wanted to be a dad let me
tell you I love it did you do another
drawing over family contact me doing and
moving over here for a video now you
drew my hair
well it's well drawn okay I'm their
stepdad the way I see it anyone can be a
father but not everyone has the patience
of a devotion to be able odesi super to
make your acquaintance I'm not gonna
give you my social security number
cholesterol 180 credit score 758 very
proud of that yeah I guess I could pick
you up I mean kids to the end of the day
they know who's been around
/ - ah well kind to say that thank you
the king of c-word that is Dominion was
being ruled over by some curly-headed
step king with good credit no sounds
like your dad spending part of your
actually it's getting late
good night little magical cherubs
escalope hmm
what's kinetically good night back
scratches okay who's 20 bucks
the kids to someone here now I don't
know if you guys can argue love I
thought you were talking about me well
you have a dog breath place is looking
good over here man it's a tree house
been here for about two months
I like the concept
what's up to code
okay
take her out see what she can do
remember one down four up everyone knows
one now
oh my god I'll just be grateful nobody
got hurt okay I got hurt right - stay
still I'll get you no please just go and
get a shirt this is for doing a vegan
dish and it was nothing but net
[ __ ] attending Mark Wahlberg looks like
he's out of 4 brothers again and I
thought of another one another another
one the other guys more like the other
dad that movie looks like a hoot I love
the idea of stepdad vs. dad set up in a
very smart way where the dads not
necessarily a bad guy but you know it's
like the intimidating [ __ ] and
naturally he will because he's the
actual biological father but that
position of a stepfather who's actually
been the dad it's a terrible thing to
put children in that conflict but I
suppose it'll make for a good comedy I'm
just excited to see Mark Wahlberg in
Wolfeboro pairing up again they work
great together this movie looks like
it'll add ifferent kind of humor but I'm
sure it'll still be funny because like I
like the two they're coming together
because they play characters when they
come together they're not just Will
Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg but that
ending I I was not expecting that that
and hitting the girl and that's pretty
[ __ ] funny yeah I mean what more can
you say it's a comedy it looks like it's
going to be a fun time a fun family time
whereas the other guys was you know for
a pg-13 and above audience this looks
like it could be a good family film
anyway guys thanks for tuning into this
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can also Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine or if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
for things such as got nowhere props I'm
going to do a shout-out instead
Louis I'm Hal Gomez
hey Ryan my name is Luis Gomez I was
hoping if you could give my YouTube
account a shout out my YouTube account
is agent 300 go check this guy out I
know a lot about him and I have a lot of
gaming content on my profile as well as
me raging on my videos too I really hope
that you could shout me out because I
really love watching your videos and
watching you make funny jokes thank you
in advance for your funny content well
Luis angel Gomez I am glad that you
think I am funny if anyone thinks I'm
funny it's me I'm my number one audience
and I think that's true with almost
anybody think about how many jokes have
you made that no one has laughed at Luis
I'm sure you understand you make plenty
of jokes and no one Lassa
but how many jokes have you made Luis
that no one laughs at but you make is
you thought it was funny
meaning you think you're funnier than a
lot of [ __ ] people so Luis quit being
a cocky little bastard you want
promotion from me you're gonna have to
earn it
okay I can't just go out there talk
about angel 300l you do raging and
gaming videos no you've got to earn it
as much as I want to say check out angel
300 I'm going to do that today